[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship
july 29 momenthouse.com tinymeatgang
tell them what we're doing we're doing
it's gonna be so much fun we got dj's
head from spock
we got a live that's cringe we're doing
a new cody noel do we're premiering it
no one's ever seen it we learned how to
sword fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and
we got some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
around might have some special guests
drop by all around good time
so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for
24 hours after the show happens so in
case you bought a ticket but you miss it
you can still watch it for the day after
but after that
this finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
momenthouse.com
you know what this also makes me realize
how much [ __ ] too hot to handle stole
from love island oh yeah everything yeah
every single mechanic that you they use
in that show they stole
yeah [ __ ] up and that's not you know
i don't i don't even support it dude
you know you won't even watch it i don't
even watch that [ __ ] bro
how dare you bring up that name i am
pissed that you just brought that up
honestly too hot to handle is just like
basically now it's like oh i mean like
now it's it's always been since the
first season it's just a road to being
tick-tock famous
it's like a micro bachelor it is that's
what it is
netflix is just like how can we make our
own batch of tick tock stars uh this is
how
like i i saw the one dude that guy had
the cockroach line on his face
that famous clip that's going all over
tick-tock yeah i went on a tick-tock
page last night or came up on my for you
page and it's just all him making jokes
about the cockroach moment and they all
have over
over a million views it's like it's just
a recipe
yeah you know well you know
that's what's cool about love island you
could be anything when you come out of
love island
exactly i mean you could be a boxer
you could be a boxer look at tommy i
mean look at molly they're [ __ ]
killing it
they're killing it i have not looked at
either their socials oh dude they're
killing it man
someone from london tell please tell me
if they're actually like big celebrities
there because it seems like molly is
like kind of a fashion person icon now i
guess
maybe i mean maybe i'm wrong but also
tommy's like winning
boxing matches yeah i mean you could put
a
little asterisk next to his opponents
but oh really
yeah what if you look at their records
ah
so there's padding it's padding yeah i
think tom tommy's still in the beginning
of his career so
that aspect but i mean the dude is
[ __ ] huge
yeah he's massive can you bring up
tommy's tommy fury's instagram right now
um on the screen real fast his dude is
gigantor just because his arms actually
look like our arms right now
yeah i'm really glad that he put the
time into finally and he he used to dm
us he's like i
want to look like he's you know we gave
him our workout plan and
we're finally here all right let me look
up molly may yeah how many followers
like there's look how many how many
likes did she get
you know for all the bagging people did
on her like interest in tommy being fake
and all that
they're still together yeah they are and
they're they're uh they seem to be
they seem to be in love you know holy
[ __ ] i mean as everyone says in
instagram what you see on instagram
normally is uh uh
accurate representation of real life
what's going on in real life a thousand
percent so
just she blew up on on the ground 5.6
million followers that's what i'm saying
this is crazy that's what i'm saying
yeah it's not love island is a
you know a jumping off platform for
anything a lot of anyone
yeah carrington uh you know i stopped by
my place
and we chatted for a little bit he just
got an agent he's working on stuff
yeah you know it's like he was on season
one of love island u.s like which
arguably wasn't that popular
right you know it was like still new
yeah
to the states yeah oh and actually
why don't we talk about this too hold on
yeah go go scroll down
scroll down scroll down okay look at
hold on just scroll back up
maybe that bottom middle picture yeah
that bottom middle picture is the
hilarious one you just got to open it
anytime
his i mean he's got to be on the juice a
little bit
[Laughter]
look at his [ __ ] arms i mean look at
his brother though
i mean you want to talk about like gumby
build these guys have like a cartoon
build
they are they they're just absurd
yeah a stature and physique yeah like
look how small their heads are
compared to their bodies like these guys
are like
like koopa troopas like
he's on the juice a little bit this is
what happens when you take the koopa
troopa's shell off this is like what's
underneath
a small ass head and it's huge
i mean they have to be on the juice
because we took trying to get like this
we had to
yeah there's no way that trend cough is
brutal that's why i've been coughing
last couple episodes
just because the trench is taking trend
yep yep
yeah yeah and uh buddy's yolked
anyways i [ __ ] suck that's part of
trend too
yeah those are the mood swings not that
anyone would care that's why we've been
doing that actually
that's cause of the trend that's not
funny yeah
our emotions are cratering under the
trend stupid callback
[ __ ] so i'm so horny i'm so horny
uh so we can talk about this so
carrington
got an agent he's he's making moves um
and you said it was did we talk about
that on the other on on the spaceship
no not really but i didn't bring that up
was it fun hanging with him yeah no it
was great i mean
we talked about how how ripped he is
you know that's about it nice and we
took some pictures
at my place and you know
i thought i was making a lot of progress
physically i got on the scale the other
yesterday i'm 162 and a half okay holy
[ __ ]
what yeah 162. yeah jesus christ
i couldn't believe and that was like
after a [ __ ]
all i had had was um like a liquid death
of water
wait are you sure 162 that's it well
this was this is before
oh okay okay you know okay this is
before i rehydrated got it
okay yeah i ate a protein bar this
morning that's why
that's why it looks so good right now
when i had a little bit of a pump when i
rehydrate and have a little creatine
and then i'm back up to 210 okay yeah
got it but without that
you know 162 and a half yeah
that's raw muscle you have to understand
it's 162 pounds of pure muscle okay
no organs or anything it's just muscle
and so
when i um when i hung out with him
i'm like how much does this [ __ ] her way
and i looked at this picture of us i'm
like
dude i i've put on size
but it looks like not at all right
compared to that dude yeah
kids got pipes i mean that's just years
and years of
every single day you know what i'm
saying there they clicked that picture
this is yeah this is before i started
trend
okay so this is before your cycle this
is before my cycle yeah trend actually
is a really short cycle mm-hmm
it's like so you only need to take it
for a couple days or a couple minutes
and then you just get huge and then you
can sometimes just feel it start
yeah and your shirt sometimes just ends
up ripping pushing
out of your whole body bro um
wait hold on we didn't even sorry what
were you going to say
because i do want to cover up like i
want to talk about one other thing in
that in the episode
okay well i was going to talk just while
we're on the subject of past
love island people doing crazy things
i've been listening to wes nelson's
music non-stop
oh this is amazing non-stop yeah like
the dude's music is unbelievable
check that guy out wes where's nelson
spotify what's crazy was
when we were in um we're at the reading
festival
yeah and we saw him yeah oh yeah did we
even did we ever
tell the story on the podcast uh we i
think we did
okay yeah we like ran into him at a
selfridges
yeah him and him and meg yeah two people
two of our like i mean two like the
they went really far in season three was
it or four
and it was like he was four you know we
had just it was four
we just finished watching the show and
we were going to london
with post and then and we were like i
wonder
guys and i were like i wonder if there's
any chance we're going to see the island
people but it's like
london's a [ __ ] huge place you know
we ended up running into them in the
sulphur ziz yep
and they recognized post obviously but
then we
were with him so we started chatting
with him we like made friends with him
basically
yeah and then we hung out with him
backstage at the writing festival
yeah and so when we were back there
um someone started playing
uh someone started playing beats and
people started like freestyling and
wes kind of like he perked up and then
he he like uh he i think he like
i forgot what he's like how it started
but he basically kind of leaned over to
me and was like
he's like oh they really want to do that
right now like
um i'm i'm gonna get in there and i was
like oh you
i'm like oh do you like do you spit fire
yeah i was like you rap like and then he
and he was like he was like oh yeah
he's like no trust me like he had like
this like
he's like i'm gonna do music that's what
he told me and so when he got the label
deal i was like damn he's really going
after it
and then from his first song i'm like
yeah i mean it's not really grime it's
like more singing no this is saying 100
this isn't grime at all
but it's it's really [ __ ] good yeah
like his his
melodies are so simple but really catchy
yeah
no he's he's he kills it yeah i've been
listening to him nonstop
he could sing his ass off too that's
what i'm saying man world's your oyster
after love island you know that's what
makes this show so beautiful
and you know what another thing i was
just thinking about it's like
as we're talking about all the people
from the [ __ ] show that we've met
and interacted with i always think like
we got to be careful how much [ __ ] we
talk
yeah because it'll bite us in the ass
once we
because we always end up meeting these
people so yeah you know so after all
that [ __ ] we talked about that teacher
he's for sure gonna be just walking down
the street
absolutely he'll be wearing a tmg hoodie
and he'll be like i love you guys
i'm gonna have to run back
to that right here on the whiteboard you
[ __ ] loser oh god
just double down and bully him
what's up puss bag nice to meet you nah
that's that's messed up because i think
we called meg crazy maybe and then we
ended up hanging out with her and she
was like
cool in real life yeah her and kelsey
are like still friends i think
i don't know meg is super normal yeah so
um so you know what everyone on the show
is great
super well adjusted everyone's really
smart and everyone's a perfect fan
so this is not a drill inclu including
hugo
including hugo south west though man he
uh
he's doing great things yeah go listen
to his music guys
he's really good um maybe we can get him
on the maybe we can get him on
we should have passed people out on as
guests like just even
via zoom i mean i think he's just way
too cool for this now but
well where's if you're watching yeah
my if you'd like to stop in and perhaps
say something to the people let us know
have a chat yeah if you'd like to have a
chat
let us know man i mean i don't want to i
feel like we might be a little bit
intimidating now
yeah you know i mean even on zoom i
can't even imagine
people not very scared they're being
scared even
these bodies so bro when
when toby was sucking kaz's toe
[Music]
and jake started filming it great segway
when jake started
owning it yeah like from here yeah he
was like i'm filming it i'm filming it
why would you
telling people you're filming it makes
it weird so you can go spank off
that's what i'm saying like that to me
was like he got caught
right he was you know he didn't want to
get in trouble for that
yeah and then for him to immediately go
how'd it taste
that is like blatant
that's like he's gonna start only fans
after this show is over yeah
with all the clips he gets the world is
your oyster
[Laughter]
jake jake the toe sucks